speaking of treats Tom it is your
special day today and we know you insist
on not making a big deal out of it but
we couldn't really take a look it's not
John my birthday the conversation about
economics finance investment in
birthdays information to get to write
happy birthday Tom thank you for a great
year and a half you need to follow Cobie
at all time remember shoes it's Tom's
birthday it reminds me of my time
playing squash at st. Paul's and how
that dovetails with my experience in
Frankfurt nobody cares
my name is not Taniya it's Tanya it's
Brandon let's go to store food what do
we have going on today I understand
you're going to drinks at the Carlyle
and then the second floor at Bergdorf
through nice birthday Tom and I wanted
to wish you a very happy birthday happy
birthday Tom happy birthday happy
birthday wishing you a happy birthday
happy birthday Tom happy birthday hope
you have a good one okay you know I
stopped celebrating 29 no you can't stop
celebrating because we're by way of
explanation by the way in that video
there was a Brandon trying to explain
his name we have on staff a Brendan a
Brandon and a brand on it smells a dip
well we we tom uses the Royal we Tom
calls us by the where we went to school
because the otherwise gets confused
Cambridge show up at the store why pick
chocolate we actually carried in the
hotel so I'm not sure what they had they
might have had chocolate they might had
some gummies but we do hope to be a lot
surveillance breaks loose of Kate with
gummies from Dylan's Ken that's candy
bracelet 4x reports brought to you by
dark chocolate cupcakes this morning